the creation of the student home Ohio
League the very first gay student group
in the world right happens here at
Columbia in 1966 it gets official
University recognition in 1967 but it's
not the beginning of the story of gay
people at Columbia we have the famous
examples in the 1940s of Allen Ginsberg
Jack Kerouac the the foundation of the
Beat movement which opened up a whole
sort of discussion in post-war America
about homosexuality
these students were nurtured by the
great professors like Lionel trilling
and Mark Van Doren and this throughout
the whole history of the gay rights
movement at Columbia even when the
university might be trying to quiet
things down nonetheless there was this
atmosphere in this environment that was
nurturing the rebel nurturing those who
were going to challenge the system even
the the heavy sexual mores of post-war
America